we begin with some breaking news U.S
media Mogul Rupert Murdoch has announced
he'll step down as chairman of fox and
news corporation the 92 year old created
Fox broadcasting in 1986. it eventually
became the number one cable news channel
in the U.S known for carrying Republican
talking points his son Lachlan Murdock
will become the sole chairman of both
companies
let's go to Heidi Joe Castro for more on
this so how is this news being received
there Heidi
see
well it is a pretty earth-shattering
thing in the media landscape here in the
United States but certainly one that has
been expected given the age of Rupert
Murdoch who is now 92 but he has long
been such an act of presence guiding his
two companies Fox Corporation and news
Corps and really actively involved in
the editorial guidance particularly at
Fox News which of course is the leading
conservative voice
among the media in the United States so
given his age this is not altogether
unexpected however he did write in this
memo to employees this morning that he
is staying on as the chair emeritus of
both of these companies which is also
unsurprising now who is going to take on
the role of the chief executive well
Murdoch Rupert Murdoch has two sons and
the one that he is giving these
companies to is also the one that people
have long expected and that is Lachlan
Murdock who has already been basically
running these companies with his
father's guidance over uh the last few
years we're not expecting too big of a
change given that this is the son who
has already been helming the ship under
his father's guidance for these last few
years however there there could be
changes coming as any shake-up of this
of this type but of course again why
we're paying such important such close
attention to this is given the important
role that Fox News in particular has
played in the U.S media landscape and
its influence on politics it has been
credited for really elevating uh Donald
Trump eventually who won the presidency
and it remains one of his strongest
supporters even though Trump himself has
split off and decried Fox News for being
unfair to him in the recent past but
this certainly has the potential for
really shaking things up as we are still
eyeing the next presidential election
next year all right thanks so much Heidi
Joe Castro there